Voiceover: What I want to
do in this video is think
about the electron
configuration for an atom
whose highest energy electron
is not in the S block
or the P block but the D block.
And to help us think about that with
the periodic table, I'm going to rearrange
the periodic table a little bit.
I'm gonna take Helium,
which it makes sense
that's it's right over
here in the top right
because it's a noble gas,
it's inert like the other
noble gases, has very similar properties.
But for the purpose of
electron configurations,
because Helium's highest
energy electron is in the
S sub-shell it's electron
configuration is essentially 1S2.
I'm gonna put it over here
and then that allows us
to construct, essentially, an S block.
So let me cut and paste that here.
So what do I mean by an S block?
Well that means that
any of these, there are
some exceptions, but
the general rule is that
if an element is sitting
in this block it's highest
energy electron is going
to be in an S sub-shell.
So this is the S block right over there.
Now, for example,
Potassium's highest energy
electron is going to
be in the 4S sub-shell.
While Hydrogen's highest energy electron,
of course, is in the 1S sub-shell.
But it's going to be in an S sub-shell.
Now that allows us to divide the rest
of the periodic table to other blocks.
This right over here is
the P block, same idea.
The general rule is that
the highest energy electron
in the electron configuration
of these elements
is going to be in a P sub-shell.
So this is the P block right over there.
And, as you might have guessed,
this in the middle is the D block.
This is the D block and we'll talk about
the F block in a future video.
This is the F block.
And you can actually place
it here and kind of push
over the D and the P blocks
to make space for this.
But we'll do that in a future video.
So this right over here is the D block.
Now why is this helpful?
Well, if something is in
the D block we can say
that it's highest energy
electron and there's
going to be some special
cases, but we can say,
in general, the highest energy electron
is going to be sitting in a D sub-shell.
So, for example, if we
were to focus on Iron,
it's highest energy electron is going
to be in a D sub-shell.
Now the D sub-shell starts
to become interesting.
For something like the S and P sub-shells,
you can say look at
Oxygen, and you can say
"OK, Oxygen's in the P block it's highest
"energy electron is going
to be in a P sub-shell."
And you can even look at
its period and you can say
"OK, it's going to be
in the 2P sub-shell."
You can actually figure
out its configuration.
It's going to be 1S2, 2S2,
and then 1, 2, 3, 4, so 2P4.
Actually let me just write
that down just for fun.
Just for a review so we can compare them.
So Oxygen we have 1S2,
you fill that sub-shell.
Then you go to 2S2, you fill that up,
you're in the second period.
And now you're gonna
have 1, 2, 3, 4 electrons
in the 2P sub-shell.
And how did I know it was 2P?
I'm in the second period, 2P.
So, 2 or the second row
I guess you could say
of the Periodic Table, so 2P4.
So 1S2, 2S2, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Now you might be tempted when you're doing
the electron configuration
for, say, something
like Iron, you fill all
these up, you got the 4S2,
although you might
tempted to say 4D1, 4D2,
4D3, so on and so forth,
but the D sub-shell
you actually back fill
into the third shell.
So the thing to remember
is when you're thinking
about which sub-shell you're
filling, say, for Iron,
and you might say OK, Iron
is in the fourth period,
but when you're thinking
about the D sub-shell
you're gonna take that period minus one.
So its highest energy
electron isn't going to be
in the 4, it's not going
to be in the 4D sub-shell,
but it's going to be in the 3D sub-shell.
But let's make that a little more concrete
by figuring out its entire
electron configuration.
So this right over here is Iron.
So let's see, 1S2, 2S2,
then we fill out the P block
to get up to electron
configuration of Neon.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 in the P block.
So 2P6 and then we come
to the third shell.
We're gonna have 3S2 again.
And then we're gonna
fill up the P sub-shell
of the third shell so this is going
to be 3P6 to get to the electron
configuration of Argon, so 3P6.
And then we go to 4S2.
And now we're going to
fill, not the 4D sub-shell,
but the 3D sub-shell for the D block.
You take the period minus
one, where in the fourth
period we're gonna take one less of that.
So the general rule you
could think of it as 3D1
3D2, 3D3, 3D4, 3D5, 3D6, so 3D6.
And so that's its electron configuration.
We've gotten to the D sub-shell.
Now this is an interesting
thing because when
you think about its outer most electrons,
the outermost electrons are the ones that
are in the fourth shell.
They're those right over there.
But if you were to think
about its highest energy
electrons those are the
3D6, but they go back fill.
One other way to think
about it is we've seen these
kind of, 3D visualizations
of how orbitals look.
They're these probability
distributions that these
electrons fall into depending
on their energy state.
And one way to think about
it is it starts to...
These higher energy electrons are filling
in kind of a three dimensional probability
distribution gap in the third shell.
So the outermost electrons are in this
4S sub-shell but the highest energy ones,
one way to think about it,
are in the 3D sub-shell.